JUAN WILLIAMS, JESSE WATTERS AND
GREG GUTFELD.
IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY, AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE" ."
NO MORE DEALS ON DREAMERS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SPENDING POWDER
TOOK PART OF EASTER SUNDAY
FUMING ON THE IMMIGRATION AGENDA
FUMING ON THE IMMIGRATION AGEND
AGENDA.
URGING REPUBLICANS TO USE THE
NUCLEAR OPTIONS FOR NEW BORDER
LEGISLATION.
HE SAID: DACA IS DEAD.
>> MEXICO HAS GOT TO HELP US ON
THE BORDER.
A LOT OF PEOPLE WANT TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF DACA.
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TWO SEE.
THEY HAD A GREAT CHANCE.
THE DEMOCRATS BLEW IT.
THEY HAD A GREAT, GREAT CHANCE.
WE'LL HAVE TO TAKE A LOOK.
>> Dana: SARAH SANDERS
FOLLOWED UP ON FOX NEWS EARLIER.
>> THE PRESIDENT MADE MULTIPLE
OFFERS ON DACA.
HE WANTED TO SEE SOMETHING GET
DONE.
DEMOCRATS REFUSED TO PUT
SOMETHING ON THE TABLE OR WORK
WITH THE PRESIDENT TO GET
ANYTHING DONE.
THEY WANTED THESE DACA
RECIPIENTS AS POLITICAL PAWNS.
THE PRESIDENT WANTED TO MAKE A
DEAL.
HE MADE TWO INCREDIBLY GENEROUS
OFFERS THAT WENT FAR AND ABOVE
EVEN WHAT THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION HAD DONE ON DACA.
DEMOCRATS STILL REFUSED TO MAKE
A DEAL.
I THINK IT'S BECAUSE WE'RE
GETTING CLOSE TO AN ELECTION.
THEY DON'T WANT TO SEE THE
PRESIDENT CONTINUE TO WIN BACK
LIKE HE HAS FOR THE LAST YEAR
AND A HALF.
>> Dana: JESSE, I WILL GO TO
FIRST.
THERE IS A DEBATE ON WHO KILLED
DACA.
I THINK THE TRUTH IS IT WASN'T
GOING TO GO ANYWHERE BEFORE THE
MIDTERM ELECTION.
EVERYONE IS GOING TO TRY TO
UTILIZE IT FOR THEIR ADVANTAGE.
>> Jesse: EXACTLY.
THE PRESIDENT OFFERED A VERY
GENEROUS PROPOSAL.
CRYING CHUCK DENIED IT.
PRESIDENT OBAMA PUT FORTH DACA.
HE KNEW IT WAS UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
HE HAD SAID HE WASN'T ALLOWED TO
DO IT AS PRESIDENT.
THEN HE CHANGED AND DID IT.
IT WAS CHALLENGING THE COURTS.
IT WAS ABOUT TO GET REJECTED, SO
THE PRESIDENT SAYS LET'S HAVE
CONGRESS DEAL WITH IMMIGRATION
LAW BECAUSE THAT'S THE RIGHT
PLACE TO DEAL WITH IMMIGRATION
LAW.
HE COMES OUT AND PUTS FORTH AN
ARRANGEMENT WHICH I THOUGHT WAS
OVERLY GENEROUS.
1.8 MILLION AMNESTY IN EXCHANGE
FOR WALL FUNDING.
THAT WAS REJECTED.
THE PRESIDENT TRY TO MAKE IT A
BROADER SOLUTION AND SAY OKAY
LET'S PUT THINGS THAT THE
AMERICAN VOTE WANT ON THE TABLE.
MERIT-BASED IMMIGRATION SYSTEM
AND DOING AWAY WITH THE VISA
LOTTERY AND CHAIN MIGRATION.
75% OF THE COUNTRY BELIEVES
THAT.
THAT WAS REJECTED AS WELL.
NOW WE ARE IN A SITUATION WHERE
THE DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO
CAMPAIGN IN THE MIDTERMS THAT
THE REPUBLICANS HATE HISPANICS
AND THE REPUBLICANS WILL
CAMPAIGN AS "THE DEMOCRATS WANT
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION AND OPEN
BORDERS.
WILL WE WILL SEE WHICH NARRATIVE
WINS.
>> Dana: DNC DEPUTY CHAIR
KEITH ELLISON ON WHAT HE THINKS.
>> BACK WHEN TRUMP ENDED THE
DACA PROGRAM IN SEPTEMBER, I
KNEW HE WASN'T GOING TO DO
ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
HE NEVER HAD A PLAN FOR TRYING
TO FIX DACA AND HE TURNED DOWN
SEVERAL BIPARTISAN DEALS.
THIS WAS ALWAYS A GAME, A TRICK,
HE WAS NEVER ARGUING IN GOOD
FAITH.
>> Dana: THE PRESIDENT DID PUT
A PRETTY GENEROUS PLAN ON THE
TABLE FOR GOING BEYOND THE DACA
KIDS TO SAY UP TO 8 MILLION HE
WOULD BE WILLING TO DO AMNESTY.
IT COULDN'T GET DONE.
IS IT FAIR TO SAY THAT FOR THE
DEMOCRATS THIS IS AN ELECTION
ISSUE THAT'S BETTER THAN SOLVING
THE PROBLEM?
>> Juan: NO.
HOW I THINK THE DEMOCRATS WOULD
LIKE TO CROW THAT THEY HAVE
SOLVED THE PROBLEM, AND SAVED
THE DREAMERS.
WHAT YOU SEE IS THE PROPOSAL THE
PRESIDENT PUT FORWARD DIDN'T
HAVE THE SUPPORT OF ENOUGH
REPUBLICAN VOTES IN THE SENATE
TO GET PAST HER REPUBLICANS
DIDN'T BACK WHAT THE
PRESIDENT -- NO HE DIDN'T.
>> Dana: HE HAD 36.
>> Juan: HE DIDN'T HAVE 52
REPUBLICANS BEHIND HIM.
WHAT STRUCK ME WAS HOW LITTLE
RELATIONSHIP THERE IS BETWEEN
WHAT THE PRESIDENT WAS TWEETING
AND REALITY.
HE SAID THERE IS A CARAVAN OF
PEOPLE FROM HONDURAS, GUATEMALA
TRYING TO MAKE THEIR WAY TO THE
U.S. BORDER.
TO REQUEST ASYLUM BECAUSE THEY
ARE FLEEING FROM THE CRIME AND
CAST ON THERE.
THE PRESIDENT SAYS THESE PEOPLE
ARE TRYING TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THE DREAMERS.
THEY CAN'T APPLY FOR DREAMERS
STATUS.
THERE IS NO RELATIONSHIP.
HE MAKES IT OUT IF -- AS IF
THERE IS ONE.
>> Jesse: IT IS RELATED.
IF YOU CROSS THE BORDER
ILLEGALLY AS A MIGRANT SEEKING
ASYLUM, YOU WILL GET SPECIAL
TREATMENT AND THEY WILL CONSIDER
YOU FOR AMNESTY.
>> Juan: NO, THEY WILL
CONSIDER YOU FOR ASYLUM.
>> Jesse: AMNESTY OR ASYLUM,
YOU STILL GET TO STAY IN THAT
COUNTRY.
>> Juan: THERE'S A HUGE
DIFFERENCE.
IN ORDER TO QUALIFY FOR DACA,
YOU HAVE TO HAVE BEEN IN THE
COUNTRY, COME IN THE COUNTRY AT
A YOUNG AGE.
>> Jesse: THERE IS NO ARGUMENT
THAT NOT HAVING A BORDER WALL
AND THE DACA SITUATION STILL IN
PLAY DOES ATTRACT ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
>> Dana: KIMBERLY, IF YOU ARE
BEING TECHNICAL, THESE PEOPLE,
CHILDREN BEING ACROSS THE BORDER
BY THE PARENTS.
BUT IT'S TRUE THERE IS A
CARAVAN.
COMES AROUND EVERY YEAR.
THIS IS THE FIFTH YEAR THIS
GROUP IS TRYING TO DO THIS.
THEY TRIED TO DETER THEM.
YOU ARE NOT GOING TO GET ASYLUM.
YOU MIGHT BE ABLE TO TRY TO
APPLY FOR IT.
NIKKI HALEY WAS IN HONDURAS THIS
PAST SPRING SAYING WE WANT TO
HELP YOU SOLVE THE PROBLEM AT
THE SOURCE BUT YOU'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO PARTNER WITH US.
>> Kimberly: ISN'T IT
REASONABLE?
GO TO THE SOURCE THE PROBLEM AND
SAY WE WOULD LIKE TO PARTNER
WITH YOU, FIND A POSITIVE
SOLUTION.
NEVERTHELESS, YOU CAN'T
FLAGRANTLY VIOLATE THE LAW AND
EXPECT A LOT TO SHOW YOU
CONSIDERATION AT EXPENSE TO
OTHERS WHO ARE COME PORTING
THEMSELVES IN AN APPROPRIATE
MATTER FOLLOWING THE LEGAL
GUIDELINES.
NOBODY IS TRYING TO STEP ON
ANYBODY'S DREAMS OR HOPES OR
ABILITY TO GET INTO THIS
COUNTRY.
WHAT PEOPLE ARE AGAINST IS
ILLEGAL ENTRY.
THE DEMOCRATS MISSED A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THE POSITIONING.
WHAT HE WANTED TO GET THE
25 BILLION FOR THE ENHANCED
BORDER WALL.
INSTEAD THEY WENT AHEAD AND
PASSED ON IT FOR POLITICAL
REASONS WHICH IS A DISSERVICE TO
EVERYONE.
80% OF WHAT THEY WANTED.
HE WAS SAYING LISTEN, WE HAVE TO
SLOW IT DOWN ABOUT THIS IN TERMS
OF CHAIN MIGRATION, THE LOTTERY
SYSTEM.
PUT SOME MORE SPECIFIC STANDARDS
AND PRACTICES, LITTLE MORE
STRUCTURE TO MAKE SURE THE RIGHT
PEOPLE ARE GETTING IN AND IT'S
PROPERLY BACKGROUND VETTED.
THAT'S NOT AN UNREASONABLE
REQUEST.
WHAT'S UNREASONABLE IS THE
OBSTRUCTIONISTS ON BOTH SIDES TO
BE FRANK BECAUSE PEOPLE ACTED
LIKE POLITICAL PARTY PIGS AND
THEY WANTED EVERYTHING THEY
WANTED ON THEIR PLATE WITHOUT AN
ABILITY OR REASON TO COMPROMISE.
THIS IS WHAT WE HAVE.
THE PRESIDENT DIDN'T KILL DACA.
I THINK THE DEMOCRATS KILLED IT.
PEOPLE WHO WERE TOO ENTRENCHED
IN THEIR OWN POLITICAL BELIEFS
AND WEREN'T WILLING TO
COMPROMISE.
>> Juan: WAIT A SECOND.
WHO KILLED DACA?
THE PRESIDENT.
>> Kimberly: NO, HE DID NOT.
>> Dana: SORT OF A
TIT FOR TAT.
BASICALLY IT'S NOT GETTING DONE
BEFORE THE ELECTION.
>> Greg: IT IS LIKE "MURDER ON
THE ORIENT EXPRESS."
THEY ALL KILLED DACA.
OKAY, I RUINED IT FOR YOU.
I LOVE AGATHA CHRISTIE.
I BELIEVE THIS GROUP WHO WAS
HELPING THE HUNTER AND REFUGEES
WERE HIRED BY TRUMP.
HERE IS A SINGULAR EXAMPLE THAT
UNDERLINES THE NECESSITY FOR
PLAN WHICH IS A WALL WITH A
DOOR, WHICH IS WHAT TRUMP IS
TALKING ABOUT.
WEAVING IN A GROUP OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS IS NOT A PLAN.
A WALL WITH A DOOR IS A PLAN.
THIS VALIDATES HIS CONCERNS OVER
A WEEK BORDER.
EVEN MEXICO KNOWS THIS IS WRONG.
THEY DEPORTED TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF HONDURANS.
YET IT IS "HEY, COME ON THROUGH.
BACK TO THE POINT ABOUT DACA,
WHO KILLED DACA.
I THINK THE DEMOCRATS SACRIFICE
THE PEOPLE THEY HAVE USED AS
PAWNS FOR SO LONG JUST A SCORE
AGAINST DONALD TRUMP.
THIS TRUMP DEAL WOULDN'T SOLVE
EVERYTHING BUT THEY DIDN'T WANT
THE SOLUTION UNLESS IT INVOLVED
A HUMILIATION OF TRUMP.
TRUMP WAS GIVING 1.6 MILLION.
>> Dana: HE WAS WILLING TO GO
UP TO 8 MILLION.
IT'S NOT THE FIRST TIME THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE DONE THIS.
2007, THAT DEAL WAS ON THE TABLE
2007, THAT DEAL WAS ON THE TABL
TABLE.
THEY BLOCKED IT THEN.
>> Greg: IN BUSINESS, IF THE
DEAL GIVES YOU WHAT YOU WANT,
DOESN'T MATTER IF YOU DON'T GET
ALONG.
YOU CAN GET A DEAL WITH PEOPLE
YOU DON'T LIKE.
BUT IN POLITICS, THERE ARE NO
SUCH RULES.
YOU CAN KILL A DEAL AND GET
REWARDED FOR IT BECAUSE IT
REWARDS YOUR SIDE.
THERE IS NO POLITICAL
CONSEQUENCES.
>> Jesse: TO YOUR POINT ABOUT
THE RESPONSIBILITY OF BOTH
PARTIES SCUTTLING THE DEAL, IF
YOU LOOK AT THE REPUBLICANS, A
LOT OF THOSE PEOPLE IN THE
POCKET OF BIG BUSINESS, THEY
WANT A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF OPEN
BORDERS BECAUSE THEY WANT THE
CHEAP LABOR FOR THE COMPANIES TO
COME IN.
THE DEMOCRATS WANT OPEN BORDERS
BECAUSE IT MEANS MORE VOTES AND
MORE AMNESTY.
MEANWHILE, THE MIDDLE-CLASS
AMERICAN WORKERS ARE GETTING
HOSED.
THE BODY POLITIC SUFFERERS AND
OUR NATIONAL SECURITY SUFFERS.
YOU HAVE NO IDEA WHO'S COMING IN
THE COUNTRY.
THE HONDURAS, THE BORDER WITH
MEXICO, 500 MILES.
WE ARE SENDING MONEY TO MAKE
SURE THEY SECURE THE BORDER AND
ROOT OUT THE CORRUPTION AND TRY
TO HELP THE ECONOMY.
RIGHT NOW AT SUCH A DISASTER, IT
IS SPILLING OVER.
NO MATTER WHAT WE SPEND, WE ARE
STILL GETTING -- IN 2016, WE
STOPPED 200,000 CENTRAL AMERICAN
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS CROSSING
THROUGH MEXICO INTO THE
UNITED STATES.
THAT'S A LOT OF PEOPLE.
>> Dana: ONE OF THE REASONS I
LOOK AT THE HONDURAS TRIP NIKKI
HALEY TALK, THERE WERE SEVERAL
AREAS.
ONE WAS COMBATING DRUGS AND
GAINS.
-- DRUGS AND GANGS.
ECONOMIC TIES.
BUT REMEMBER IT WAS HONDURAS AND
GUATEMALA, TWO OF THE ONLY
COUNTRIES THAT SUPPORTED THE
PRESIDENT ON HIS PUSH TO MOVE
THE EMBASSY FROM TEL AVIV TO
JERUSALEM.
>> Juan: I WANTED TO JUMP IN
AND SAY JESSE, WE HAVE HIT A
47-YEAR LOW IN TERMS OF PEOPLE
CROSSING THE BORDER.
U.N. PRESIDENT TRUMP WANT TO, I
THINK, CREATE ELON MUSK RHETORIC
THINK, CREATE ELON MUSK RHETORI
RHETORIC.
>> Jesse: JUAN.
300,000 THEY ARE CATCHING.
>> Juan: THE NUMBERS, THE
PERCENTAGES, THIS IS A 47-YEAR
LOW.
>> Jesse: TRUMP 'FEE AS
RHETORIC.
>> Juan: THE SECOND THING IS
THESE PEOPLE ARE COMING SEEKING
ASYLUM.
AS DANA WAS DESCRIBING COME OF
THE SITUATION IN HONDURAS, THIS
IS A HUMANITARIAN CRISIS.
WE AS AMERICANS HAVE CREATED A
SYSTEM THAT ALLOWS PEOPLE TO
APPLY FOR ASYLUM.
>> Greg: YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT.
PEOPLE SHOULD APPLY.
BUT JUST BECAUSE THEY ARE CLOSER
TO US ISN'T FAIR.
THERE'S PLENTY OF PEOPLE WHO
SHOULD BE IN FRONT OF THEM WHO
HAPPEN NOT TO BE ON OUR BORDERS.
I COULD GO THROUGH THEM.
WE KNOW WHERE THEY ARE.
I CAME UP WITH AN IDEA FOR A CNN
TOWN HALL.
NOT FOR FOX NEWS BUT CNN.
WHY, WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THESE
THINGS GOING ON IN THE WORLD,
WHY IS HIS APPROVAL RATING STILL
MOVING UP?
THAT IS WORTH DISCUSSING.
WHY IS IT?
PROGRESS IN NORTH KOREA, BECAUSE
OF IMMIGRATION, BECAUSE OF BEING
TOUGH ON CHINA?
SECOND AMENDMENT?
COLLUSION THEORY DYING.
IS IT TERROR, IS IT A STORMY
BACKLASH.
THESE VARIABLES EXIST.
IT KIND OF MAKES YOU THINK, HE
MIGHT BE DOING A PRETTY GOOD JOB
MIGHT BE DOING A PRETTY GOOD JO
GOOD JOB.
>> Juan: DO YOU KNOW WHY HIS
NUMBERS --DASH RECORD NUMBER.
>> Greg: I KNEW YOUR HEAD
WOULD EXPLODE.
I THINK A LOT OF THIS HAS TO DO
WITH PEOPLE SAYING HE IS THE
PRESIDENT.
WE ARE PATRIOTS.
>> Kimberly: ALL OF A SUDDEN
THAT HAPPENED?
THEY WOKE UP?
PATRIOTISM.
50%.
>> Dana: THE GALLUP POLL TODAY
HAD HIM AT 39.
I WANT TO GIVE JUAN A LITTLE
COVER.
>> Greg: THE POINT I AM TRYING
TO MAKE IS THAT EVERYONE OF
THESE ISSUES PEOPLE ARE THROWING
OUT THERE HAS A REBOUND EFFECT
AND THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING.
AMERICANS ARE LOOKING AT THIS
AND THEY ARE LOOKING AT THE
ASSUMPTIONS TRUMP MAKES WITCHES
I'M GOING TO BE TOUGH ON
IMMIGRATION, LAW AND ORDER.
THEY LIKE IT.
ALL THESE THINGS ARE GOING ON,